a recording studio in Cairo this is the
group mod Foggia or the Gunners it's the
sound of the Cairo underground the music
is called moraga not and it stands for
an attitude the three members of Mont
fatiah come from the slums of Cairo now
in the studio they can record their
songs which are full of defiance and the
will to survive
they're working on a new song so far
without lyrics their producer Mahmoud
Rifat gives them free rein sing what you
want he says there's certainly no
shortage of topics
mom says there are so many problems in
our society there's addiction or the bad
school system that's an important topic
kids don't want to go to school anymore
and teachers don't do a decent job
either shot a hole had this buy me some
money
I've met says it's not just education
there's also traffic chaos for example
if we were to just talk about the
negative things we'd never stop but we
want to write songs about more than just
problems we want to say how to make
things better the next group is already
waiting at Mahmoud Rifat studio there
are the absolute stars of the mock raga
not seen Sadat and fifty fifties the one
with the yellow cap they're discussing a
gig abroad Mahmoud Rifat is organizing
everything they've already performed in
London and in September they head to
Berlin their celebrated as children of
the revolution but that's not so says
Rifat not all microc are not artists
write songs about the revolution he says
on the contrary only a few have done
that it hasn't been as important to them
as it was and remains to the elites with
this music and these kids also find
themselves in a kind of revolution with
themselves with their way of living and
with the question of what I can achieve
with my life with object ela Hodder elf
Haiti we drive this alarm city this is
where moraga not emerged and where it's
listened to the most in taxis for
example
Muraki not has its origins in a kind of
music called shabby popular in the 1980s
it put unconventional lyrics into simple
language initially disdained by the
elite
shabih quickly went mainstream and was
played at weddings and on the streets
especially in neighborhoods like Salaam
City one of Cairo's poorest half a
million people live here on the eastern
reaches of the capital education levels
are low here and unemployment is high
I'm supposed to meet up with Sadat and
fifty late in the afternoon when I
arrive their manager tells me they're
still asleep they got to bed at nine in
the morning four hours later 50 shows up
and wants to show me around you're in
Salaam city the birthplace of moraga not
he proudly says to the camera fifty
whose real name is Allah took his stage
name from his idol US rapper 50 cent
other Mafra gana artists have also taken
western-style stage names like aughtta
Ortega diesel and Bombo a bit of
globalization on the outskirts of Cairo
he feels at home in Salaam city not
least because his music plays everywhere
here he says it's a great feeling but
there are good and bad sides to it the
good thing is we make people happy
people like us they get our music free
of charge we don't take money for it but
we get Fame that makes me happy because
I'm recognized without these people I
wouldn't have continued with music none
of us would have especially here in
Egypt where no one gives others a chance
no one helps anyone else call this well
I had to be sad hug he tells me about a
former music producer in central Cairo
who embezzled money from his band about
intellectuals who despise people here
because of their origins
but here in Salaam City people stick
together 50 says we visit each other and
ask if they need help like this former
band member who left the music business
to operate a carwash
50 is a celebrity around here he meets
with kids just starting to write Moraga
not music they approach their Idol
almost shyly he asks if they need any
help 50 says it's the social problems in
his neighbourhood that concern him not
politics of which he has a low opinion
and if one wish he says take the Muslim
Brotherhood in the military or we can
say who's to blame look how many people
have been killed before the truth comes
out look how many families have been
destroyed isn't that right I don't like
politics because politics creates
victims far too many victims and most of
these victims are innocent that's why I
don't like politics but even when we
write a political song we're not part of
politics the military is fighting the
Muslim Brotherhood the remnants of
Mubarak against who knows what I don't
share anything with any of those parties
anyway if you asked me what I am my
answer will be I'm an Egyptian revolt
and retreat there are two sides of 50
during the week the group hardly ever
has a gig
they use the time to rehearse a computer
music software a microphone no expensive
equipment to write their songs this is
what sets their work apart hip-hop rap
and R&B beats fused with Arabic music
and lyrics most lyrics are created
spontaneously as the evening continues
the texts grow more political
before the Revolution
singing such lyrics could have gotten
them arrested the upheavals open their
eyes he says because I come from a
simple neighborhood it took me a long
time to understand that there are people
who only want power so they can live
well so they can do what they want I
used to think that the powerful worked
hard for the poor and sacrificed
themselves I always asked how all these
people were supposed to eat then I found
out that Egypt is wealthy and the
greatest wealth is the Egyptian people
themselves because moraga not comes from
poor areas Egypt does not officially
recognize it as an art form and its
musicians don't get work licenses from
the Musicians Union but 50 still makes a
living from music this is 50s day job a
wedding at a luxury hotel in Cairo the
band gets several gigs like this a week
their fee equals about 500 euros the
band has fans here too although the
Union denies work licenses for Morocco
not musicians officially because their
lyrics are vulgar this wedding is
costing tens of thousands of euros 50s
bandmates Sidhant has a different
attitude to clients like these
if the mocking in love he says when you
watch me here I'm mostly lip-synching
the song plays and I act as if I were
singing on the street in Salaam city I
put down the microphone when the music's
playing there I sing live I'm less happy
here than on the streets but it's only a
job and then they cancel the gig because
they're having to wait too long they can
afford to do that we head back to Salaam
city here weddings are celebrated on the
street and anyone can join the fun
the musicians don't take Abby here they
see it as their social duty
for these young people the music is like
a valve it lets them blow off steam in
the pressure cooker that is today's
Egypt